- [Instructor] Let's calculate
the molar solubility of calcium fluoride
if the Ksp value for calcium fluoride is
3.9 times 10 to the negative
11th at 25 degrees Celsius.
The first step is
to write the dissolution
equation for calcium fluoride.
So, solid calcium fluoride
will dissolve in solution
to form aqueous calcium two
plus ions and fluoride anions.
And to balance that out,
we need to make sure
and include a two in front
of the fluoride anions.
The next step is to set up an ICE table,
where I stands for initial concentration,
C stands for the change in concentration,
and E stands for
equilibrium concentration.
Before any of the solid
calcium fluoride dissolves,
the initial concentrations
of calcium two plus ions
and fluoride anions in solution is zero.
So we can go ahead and put a zero in here
for the initial concentration
of the ions in solution.
Some of the calcium
fluoride will dissolve,
and we don't know how much.
So I like to represent that by
writing -X on the ICE table,
where X is the concentration
of calcium fluoride
that dissolves.
Looking at the mole ratios,
it's a one-to-one mole ratio
between calcium fluoride
and calcium two plus ions.
So if we're losing X
for the concentration of calcium fluoride,
we must be gaining X
for the concentration of
calcium two plus ions.
And since it's a one-to-two mole ratio
for calcium two plus
ions to fluoride anions,
if we're gaining +X for calcium two plus,
we must gain plus +2X for fluoride anions.
So the equilibrium concentration
of calcium two plus ions is
zero plus X, or just X,
and the equilibrium concentration
of fluoride anions will be
zero plus 2X, or just 2X.
The next step is to
write the Ksp expression
from the balanced equation.
So Ksp is equal to
the concentration of
calcium two plus ions,
and since there's a coefficient of one
in the balanced equation,
that's the concentration
of calcium two plus ions
raised to the first power,
times the concentration
of fluoride anions,
and since there is a coefficient of two
in the balanced equation,
it's the concentration of
fluoride anions raised to
the second power.
Pure solids are not included
in equilibrium constant expression.
So we're going to leave calcium fluoride
out of the Ksp expression.
The concentration of ions
in our Ksp expression
are equilibrium concentrations.
Therefore we can plug in X
for the equilibrium
concentration of calcium two plus
and 2X for the equilibrium
concentration of fluoride anions.
We can also plug in the Ksp
value for calcium fluoride.
So that would give us
3.9 times 10 to the
negative 11th is equal to
X times 2X squared.
Next we need to solve for X.
So, 3.9 times 10 to the
negative 11th is equal to
X times 2X squared.
Well, 2X squared is equal to
4X squared times X is equal to 4X cubed.
So to solve for X, we need
to divide both sides by four
and then take the cube root of both sides.
So we'd take the cube
root of the left side
and the cube root of X cubed.
That gives us X is equal to
2.1 times 10 to the negative fourth.
And looking at our ICE table, X represents
the equilibrium concentration
of calcium two plus ions.
So 2.1 times 10 to the
negative fourth molar is
the equilibrium concentration
of calcium two plus ions.
For the fluoride anions,
the equilibrium concentration is 2X.
So two times 2.1 times 10 to
the negative fourth is 4.2,
let me go ahead and write that down here,
4.2 times 10 to the negative fourth molar
for the equilibrium
concentration of fluoride anions.
Our goal was to calculate
the molar solubility of calcium fluoride.
And molar solubility refers to
the concentration of
our salt that dissolved
to form a saturated
solution at equilibrium.
So if X refers to
the concentration of calcium
two plus ions at equilibrium,
looking at our mole ratios, that's also
the concentration of calcium
fluoride that dissolved.
Therefore, 2.1 times 10 to
the negative fourth molar
is also the molar solubility
of calcium fluoride.
Technically at a constant
temperature of 25 degrees,
the concentration of a
solid doesn't change.
And so you'll see most
textbooks not to put in -X
on the ICE table. I like
to just put it in though
to remind me that X in
this case does refer to
the molar solubility.